I read that you fell in love with the
idea of space and space exploration when
you were five watching Neil Armstrong
walking on the moon so let me uh ask you
to look back at the historical context
and impact of that so the space race
from 1957 to
1969 between the Soviet Union and the US
was in many ways epic it was um a rapid
sequence of dramatic events for
satellite to space first human to space
first space walk first un crude landing
on the moon then some failures
explosions deaths on both sides actually
and then the first human walking on the
moon uh what are some of the more
inspiring moments or insights you take
away from that time those few years that
just uh 12 years well I mean there's so
much inspiring there um you know one of
the great things to take away from that
one of the great Von Brown quotes is I
have
uh I have come to use the word
impossible with great
caution yeah yeah and so that's kind of
the big story of Apollo is that things
you know the uh going to the moon was
literally an analogy that people used
for something that's impossible you know
oh yeah you'll do that when when you
know men walk on the Moon Yeah and of
course it finally happened um so you
know I think it was pulled forward in
time because of the Space Race I think
you know with the geopolitical
implications and you know how much
resource was put into it you know at the
peak that program was spending you know
two or 3% of
GDP uh on the Apollo program so much
resource that I think it was pulled
forward in time you know we kind of did
it ahead of when we quote unquote should
have done it yeah um and so in that way
it's also a technical Marvel I mean it's
truly incredible it's uh you know it's
the 20th century version of building the
pyramids or something it's you know it's
an achievement that um because it was
pulled forward in time and because it
did something that had previously been
thought impossible it rightly deserves
its place as you know in the pantheon of
great human achievements and of course
you named uh the projects the rockets
that blue origin is working on after
some of the folks involved I don't
understand why I didn't say new gagaran
I is that there an American bias in the
naming I apologize
very
strange just asking for a friend clarify
I'm a big fan of garens though and fact
I um I think his his first words in
space um I think are incredible he you
know he purportedly said my God it's
blue and that really drives home no one
had seen the Earth from space no one
knew that we were on this blue planet
yeah no one knew what it looked like
from out there and gagaran was the first
person person to see it one of the
things I think about is how
dangerous those early days were for
gagaran for for Glenn for everybody
involved like how how big of a risk they
were all taking they were taking huge
risks I'm not sure what the uh Soviets
thought about gagarin's flight but I
think that the Americans thought that
the Allen Shepard flight the flight that
you know new Shephard is named after the
first American in space he went on his
suborbital flight they thought he had
about a 75% chance of success M um so
you know that's a pretty big risk a 25%
risk it's it's kind of interesting that
Alan Shephard is not quite as famous as
John Glenn so for people don't know Alan
Shepard is the first uh astronaut the
first American in space American in
suborbital Flight correct and and then
the first orbital flight is then John
Glenn is the first American to orbit the
Earth by the way I have the most
Charming sweet incredible letter from
John Glenn which I have framed and hang
on my office wall what he say where he
tells me how uh grateful he is that we
have named new Glenn after him and he
sent me that letter about a week before
he died um and it's really an incredible
it's also a very funny letter he's he's
writing and he says you know this is a
letter about new Glenn from the original
Glenn and he's just he's got a great
sense of humor and he's very he's very
um happy about it and grateful it's
sweet does he say PS don't mess this up
or is
that no he doesn't make me look good he
doesn't do that but wait but John
wherever you are we got you covered good
uh so so back to maybe the big picture
of space when you look up at the
stars uh and think big what do you hope
is the future of humanity hundreds
thousands of years from now out in
space I would love to see you know a you
know a trillion humans living in the
solar system if we had a trillion humans
we would have at any given time a
thousand mozarts and a thousand
Einstein um that would you know our
solar system would be full of life and
intelligence and energy um and we can
easily support a civilization that large
with all of the resources um in the
solar system so what do you think that
looks like giant space stations yeah the
only way to get to that vision is with
giant space stations you know the
planetary surfaces are just way too
small um so you can I mean unless you
turn them into giant space stations or
something but but yeah we will take
materials from the Moon and from near
Earth objects and from the asteroid belt
and so on and we'll build uh giant
O'Neal style colonies um and people will
live in those and they have a lot of
advantages over planetary surfaces you
can spin them to get normal Earth
gravity you can put them where you want
them I think most people are going to
want to live uh near Earth not
necessarily in Earth orbit but in you
know uh Earth but near Earth vicinity uh
orbits and so they can move Qui you know
relatively quickly uh back and forth
between their station and Earth so I
don't I think a lot of people especially
in the early stages are not going to
want to give up Earth altogether they go
to Earth for vacation yeah same way that
you know you might go to to to
Yellowstone National Park for vacation
people will uh and the ad and no one and
people will get to choose whether they
live on earth or whether they live in
space but they'll be able to use much
more energy and much more material
resource in space than they would be
able to use on Earth one of the
interesting ideas you had is to move the
heavy industry away from Earth so people
sometimes have this idea that somehow
space
exploration is in conflict with the
celebration of the planet Earth that we
should focus on preserving Earth and and
basically your idea is that space travel
and space exploration is a way to
preserve Earth exactly this planet we've
sent robotic probes to all the planets
we know that this is the good
one yeah not the play favorites or
anything but but Earth really is the
good Planet it's an amaz it's it's
amazing the ecosystem we have here all
of the life and the Lush uh the plant
life and you know the water resources
everything this planet is really
extraordinary and of course we evolved
on this planet so of course it's perfect
for us but it's also perfect for all the
advanced life forms on this planet all
the animals and so on and so this is a
gym we do need to take care of it and as
we enter the anthropos as we get as we
humans have gotten so uh sophisticated
and large and impactful as we stride
across this planet you know it's that
that is going to as we continue we want
to use a lot of energy we want to use a
lot of energy per capita we've gotten
amazing things we we don't want to go
backwards you know if you think about
um the good old days they're mostly an
illusion like in almost every way life
is better for almost everyone today than
it was say 50 years ago or 100 years we
all we live better lives by and large
than our grandparents did and then their
grandparents did and so on and you can
see that in global illiteracy rates
Global poverty rates Global infant
mortality rates like almost any metric
you choose we're better off than we used
to be and we get you know antibiotics
and all kinds of life-saving medical
care and so on and so on and there's one
thing that is moving backwards and it's
the natural world so it is a fact that
500 years ago pre-industrial age
the natural world was
pristine um it was incredible and we
have traded some of that pristine Beauty
for all of these other gifts that we
have as an advanced society and we can
have both but to do that we have to go
to space and all of this really the most
fundamental measure is energy usage per
capita and when you look at you know you
do want to continue to use more and more
energy it is going to make your life
better in so many ways but that's not
compatible ultimately with living on a
finite planet and so we have to go out
into the solar system uh and and really
you can argue about when you have to do
that but you can't credibly argue about
whether you have to do that eventually
we have to do that exactly well you
don't often talk about it but let me ask
you on that topic about the blue ring
and the orbital Reef uh uh space
infrastructure projects what's your
vision for these so blue ring is a very
interesting spacecraft that is uh
designed to take up to 3,000 kilograms
of payload up to geosynchronous orbit or
in lunar vicinity uh it has two
different kinds of
propulsion it has chemical propulsion
and it has electric propulsion and so it
can you can be you can use blue ring in
a couple different ways you can slowly
move let's say up to geosynchronous
orbit using electric propulsion that
might take you know 100 days or 150 days
depending on how much mass you're
carrying uh and then and reserve your
chemical propulsion so that you can
change orbits quickly in geosynchronous
orbit or you can use the chemical
propulsion first to quickly get up to
geosynchronous and then use your
electrical propulsion to slowly change
your ju synchronous orbit blue ring has
um a couple of interesting feat features
it's a uh it provides a lot of services
to these payloads so the payLo could be
one large payload or it can be a number
of small payloads and it provides
thermal management it provides electric
power it provides uh compute um provides
Communications and so when you design a
payload for blue ring you don't have
it's you don't have to figure out all of
those things on your own so kind of
radiation tolerant compute is a
complicated thing to do and so we have a
an unusually large amount of radiation
tolerant compute on board blue ring and
you can your payload can just use that
when it needs to so it's a uh uh it's
sort of all these Services it's you know
it's it's like a set of apis it's a
little bit like Amazon web services but
for face payloads that need to move
about in Earth vicinity or lunar
vicinity uh aw USS space okay so uh so
Compu in space so you get you get a
giant chemical rocket to get a payload
out to over and then you have these
admins that show up this blue ring uh
thing that manages various things like
compute exactly and it can it can also
provide transportation and move you
around to different orbits including
humans you think no but blue ring is not
designed to move humans around um it's
designed to move payloads around so
we're also building a lunar Lander uh
which is of course designed to to land
humans on the surface of the
Moon